all that [ __ ] chats gonna get you hurt
[Laughter]
this was voted a pun and now it is our
next trailers revisited or as I am now
retitling this segment to something more
interesting to call trailer versus the
movie how about that does it make more
sense how accurately portrayed was the
movie we're doing Suicide Squad
comic-con trailer I remember it being
different let's find out why and then
how this segment works well you'll see
you'll see it's not just a reaction
you'll say uh-huh
you know I think I just remembered good
let's check in some work but I finally
have the worst of the worst
yep felt like a pretty serious oh yeah
that's all coming back well let's just
say I put him in a home throw away the
whole who's wrong as Amanda that some of
them have abilities oh yeah I have seen
things maybe Superman was some kind of
beacon for them to creep back from the
shadows want to assemble a task force of
the most dangerous people on the planet
that's what I think can do some good
their backyard exactly
if anything goes wrong we blame them we
have built-in deniability you know this
is a makes you think you can confess us
a great race I remember now why we're
all so sad it's just so manipulative
what the actual I can't believe this
that's right this looks I still want to
see this movie this looks like dark and
it has a deep-ass tone ooh it yeah she
was like ominous and mysterious
feels like it has a nolan vibe that go
ahead
and I'm really a Noah by some kind of
some kind of Suicide Squad
[Music]
feels like it takes its time this feels
better than this they deserve it is her
an Oscar first feels like a movie in the
movie feels like a tree
Oh
[Music]
now they say about the crazy ones huh
I'm not gonna kill you I'm just gonna
hurt ya
really really
this performance even looks better
I know quality I feel like I just
watched a movie for a trailer
dreaming is safe exactly what makes it
so different oh my god that was even
more patient and striking tonally than I
remembered and I remembered thinking of
when that Legere little line came out
let's face facts
alright primarily people don't like it I
know he has his defenders clearly a lot
of people don't like him and I would say
most and I remember thinking that
perhaps that would be the next Joker
what I'm just gonna hurt you really
really and the way they they play him
here feels like this mysterious ominous
build-up to him even with the music and
that joke the whole time I'm watching
the chair the first time I denied
where's-where's Joker arrest what we
want to see right we want to see the new
Joker and when he comes into plane and
while people were still in a debate
ground with him look like he might
actually do a serviceable job and they
made it look like you'd be scary this
feels awesome
this person should get paid more money
today why wasn't the movie anything like
this you hit the nail on the head when
you said watch it this feels like a
movie and then the movie feels like a
trailer absolutely correct well yeah
because there's just so little in this
trailer that the movie even itself
totally matches up to even the like the
Amanda Waller scene feels heavier here
than it did in the actual film and I
mean we talk about a lot just the
different takes and stuff that they use
and there were a couple moments that
again I've only seen Suicide Squad the
once in theaters and then when we watch
the extended cuts which didn't help much
there are some images in there that I
didn't quite recognize from the movie
there were some like there was that
thing with the goat's head which maybe
I'm just blanking on there was like more
a cultish looking stuff in the
background and on the seams of this
trailer and it made it look like we were
gonna maybe spend a little
I am like building a beach character
getting them all together like it looked
like assembling the team was gonna
account for a lot more of the movie or
something hey they don't make what the
threat is clear when the villain is
clear in the trailer at all they make
the idea of assembling these dangerous
threatening criminals seem like there's
an actual menace here and that there's
truly something that they'll have to
overcome the themes that the movie
wanted you to deal with oh can we trust
these guys
instead the movie ends of just being a
giant music video and it's like hyper
stylized edited mess is it the best way
I can describe maybe it's really trite
big bad that doesn't fulfill this dread
at all yeah doesn't match the characters
in the movie or the rest of the movie
itself this feels like a bit of a mood
piece of a film it's so weird to watch a
trailer and then go it's so blatantly
obvious what makes this trailer so
different than the movie action crime
thriller whereas the rest of the
trailers at least as I recall them make
them look like they want to be kick-ass
we got to remember the time in which
this trailer came out and then when the
second trailer came out because then
this trailer came out it was still
around the time of you know this was
right after BBS I don't remember if this
trailer came out post BBS or not I think
it did do you see it was really starting
to go through we got a rework [ __ ] man
yeah that's people ain't for all those
really dark moody stuff and what people
fail to realize and I think Joker really
proved that no Yorkin dad's like darker
and moodier than any of this acts
nighter that's contextually messed up
not just like dark it's really just
execution so I think with the studio
heads or whoever was running DC at the
time - I don't know whoever was running
it just didn't quite grasp really what
the main issues were so maybe there is
an ear cut maybe there is some David
Ayer version because this actually feels
more like a David Ayer film to me yeah
like a David Ayer comic book film come
book crime film exactly whereas the the
movie doesn't feel like a David Ayer
film at all which I understand like
props to him for being a team player
yeah but also can I have another being
like nah man I'm happy with the kind of
the movie the trailer or whatever you
know like it's it's great you know like
really keeping the peace on that and I
really do hope that someday just as a
curiosity he might be able to give us
the lowdown on what really happened too
because it looks like they build up the
Joker too which is a huge deal and then
the movie itself like still makes people
wonder what his original purpose was
supposed to be to it yeah it's just so
fascinating to see this moment that they
like one shot that God is all so hyped
that just did not pay off it's funny to
the Deadshot looks like a very heavy
Will Smith performance looks more along
the lines of a 7 pounds but it ended up
just being too into that I liked it yeah
I love charm and Will Smith as well the
best parts and he was one of the best
parts of the movie but this trailer
gives you a completely different
expectation and Harley Quinn seemed like
honestly I think a Harley Quinn is fine
here I mean there's really was more do
you just get a much more eccentric
version in the film as opposed to here
but even in this trailer it feels like
Harley Quinn yeah and it feels like it
matches her level of involvement in the
film and actually one of the more fun
things about revisiting this trailer and
not thinking about the contrast was just
that to see Margot Robbie from back then
you know when she was still you know
she's a big star but still on the rise
of sorts before she got to do the full
on Harley movie yeah and her being also
one of the kind of agreeably good parts
of this movie I thought it was just cool
to go back to that and see kind of the
origins of the character for her even in
just little snippets it's weird because
this is the first trailers revisited or
should I say trailer versus the movie
the whole point of this usually is to
see like okay what different takes that
they do what were the first expectations
we had what do they not really focus on
that's not in the that they really focus
on the movie but the biggest things that
we tend to notice or nitpick on our tone
pacing mood style building this movie is
not at all accurately portrayed in this
trailer yet it feels better than
the actual movie itself which I find
incredibly fascinating and also
fascinating to that like it's all there
in the movie yeah it's just not in any
arrangement that resembles a coherence
and be this yeah it doesn't give you at
all that feeling that this trailer get
even with the music choice they had here
hey yeah that's like that's a
recognizable song but in and again it's
a trope to do the slow sad cover but it
works and it looks like there's tension
here like even at the dinner table with
the yellow Nolan lighting yeah yeah man
the Waller yeah
really the word that keeps coming to
mind is it as Menace and Wow
I really wonder if there was a different
guy I there's gotta be there had to be
like a different script somewhere and it
blew my mind yeah like it's an
inexplicable movie I haven't seen this
trailers alright guys well thanks for
recommending this one it's so obvious
that it's different that I'm actually
having a hard time finding the words but
normally it's easier you find the words
this is what I'm looking for what's
different like the salvation trailer or
the orange Wolverine trailer where it's
like I see and I'm like I watched this
movie yeah what happened a Suicide Squad
grown on you are you in the camp that
likes Jared Leto's Joker performance are
you waiting for that solo movie
subscribe click that notification bell
and do us a favor leave down in the
comment boxes what else you'd like us to
do a trailers revisited or trailer
versus the movie or Greg will decide on
a title sue Jason Dolan in a lot of ways
reminds me of the way I felt about the
trailer for Suicide Squad versus the
movie met Jason online seem like he's
probably a nice guy one day let him come
to our apartment when we lived together
and I was like I don't know about this
this might be crazy
never just invited a fan of the channel
over and I was like I'm a little
hesitant I'm a little skeptical maybe
he's a creepy guy we saw that was my
first impression of Jason was this guy
is probably a freaking weirdo
to get to really know him not just off
of the preview I had of him beginning to
know him in real life he's ended up
becoming a really close friend of mine
he's even been on this channel he gave
us his camera I talked with him weekly
on text were real friends and he's still
a weirdo
oh that's never going away never so when
I revisit my friendship with Jason
completely different than the first
impression I had of him you're the
perfect person shoutout for this video
I'm not so he's like a great
screenwriter blah blah was believed I
mean costly keeps you updated on the
Panda America thank you Jason whatever
he sends me memes a lot but just know
this you're the Jared Leto of this
channel